When these mini sourdough bagels came across my feet,
I knew I had to give them a try.
My husband absolutely loves bagels,
and for some reason I have never attempted to make them until now.
This is our first attempt of making not just bagels,
but sourdough bagels.
I've talked about this before,
but I have a gluten sensitivity,
but for some reason,
Italian flour does not affect me the way normal flour does.
So I made these with Italian flower,
and I think I flatten them out a little too much.
Next time I'm definitely not going to flatten them as much as I did,
but they still turned out absolutely beautiful.
And they were so yummy for Jake and I to eat this morning. He was happy.